>> Lawrence: THE DEFENSE RESTED
THE CASE OF THE MURDER OF MOLLIE
TIBBETTS BUT NOT BEFORE THE
DEFENDANTS TAKE THE STAND HIS
TESTIMONY ADDING A BIZARRE TWIST
IN THE CASE OF THE MURDER
UNIVERSITY OF IOWA STUDENT.
FOX NEWS CORRESPONDENT MATT FINN
IS LIVE IN IOWA WITH THE LATEST
ON THAT.
MATT?
>> IT WAS QUITE A MOMENT IN
COURT TODAY.
SOME OF THE JURORS SAT FORWARD
IN THEIR SEATS WHEN THE MAN
ACCUSED OF MOLLIE TIBBETTS MADE
THE BOLD MOVE OF TAKING THE
STAND IN HIS OWN DEFENSE.
26-YEAR-OLD ILLEGAL IMMIGRANT
CHRISTIAN A RIVER'S SHOCKING
TESTIMONY CONTRADICTS WHAT HE
PREVIOUSLY TOLD POLICE REGARDING
HOW 20-YEAR-OLD MOLLIE TIBBETTS
WAS BRUTALLY STABBED TO DEATH.
RIVERA CLAIMS ON THE NIGHT
TIBBETTS WENT MISSING HE TOOK A
SHOWER AT HIS HOUSE, TWO MASKED
MEN CAME THROUGH THE FRONT CURE
THEN INSTRUCTED HIM INTO HIS CAR
TO DRIVE THEM TO MOLLIE
TIBBETTS' TOWN WHERE THEY
CIRCLED HER ON HER JOG.
RIVERA CLAIMS ON THAT RIDE ONE
OF THE MASKED MEN CALLED THE
OTHER JACK WHICH IS THE LAST
NAME OF MOLLIE TIBBETTS
BOYFRIEND.
RIVERA SAYS HE DOESN'T KNOW HOW
THE TWO ALLEGED MEN KILLED
TIBBETTS BUT AFTERWARDS HE
INSTRUCTED THEM TO DRIVE TO A
CORNFIELD AND THE TWO MEN LEFT
ON FOOT.
RIVERA CLAIMS HE DUMPED
TIBBETTS' BODY THEN LATER
REALIZED HIS CELL PHONE AND KEYS
IN MOLLIE TIBBETTS FIT BIT WERE
IN HIS TRUNK.
HE DUMPED HER CELL PHONE AND FIT
BIT ON THE SIDE OF THE ROAD AND
CLAIMS HE KEPT IT ALL A SECRET
BECAUSE HE CLAIMS THOSE MASKED
MEN THREATENED TO HARM HIS
DAUGHTER AND HER MOTHER, HIS
EX-GIRLFRIEND.
>> DO YOU REMEMBER BEING ASKED
IN THE INTERVIEW BY MS. RAMIRO
IF YOU WERE COVERING FOR ANYONE?
>> YES.
>> AND YOU TOLD HER THAT YOU
WERE NOT; IS THAT CORRECT?
>> CORRECT.
AT THAT MOMENT I WAS REALLY
SCARED.
>> I UNDERSTAND THAT YOU MAY
HAVE BEEN SCARED, BUT YOU CHOSE
NOT TO TELL HIM, CORRECT?
>> CORRECT.
>> RIVERA IS CHARGED WITH FIRST
DEGREE MURDER.
HE HAS PLEADED NOT GUILTY.
THIS CASE IS EXPECTED TO GO TO
THE JURY TOMORROW.
WE COULD BE ON VERDICT WATCH AT
SOME POINT TOMORROW, LAWRENCE.
>> Lawrence: THANK YOU, MATT.
IT'S GOT TO BE REALLY D